Говорящий 1: Смотри, я сделал такой интерактивный кабинет в двух словах.
Говорящий 2: Если скинешь мне ленд, я посмотрю, то надо будет строить вход для партнеров. Либо это отдельная страница, я просто ленд сам не видел, как там он устроен.
Говорящий 2: Стандартная наша форма, когда отправляешь письмо, тебе приходит код, ты заходишь. Это авторизация для партнеров. Партнером может стать любой. По поводу того слоя, где ты спрашивал,
Говорящий 2: как моя организация,
Говорящий 1: не организация. Слушай, ну да, получается, видишь, сейчас я секундочку открою, наверное, другой файл, кто может быть партнером. Ну или так на словах проговорю, что по сути любая
Говорящий 2: роль ей может быть присвоен партнер. То есть это может быть и эксперт, и
Говорящий 1: ученик, и там, ну, в общем, блогер какой -нибудь, неважно. То есть партнером может стать любой,
Говорящий 2: кто хочет перепродавать наши продукты. Вопрос в том, как, например, будет распределяться вот эта комиссия, мы тоже там с ребятами общались, что нам, если это физлицо, то мы, конечно,
Говорящий 2: не можем быть за него налоговым агентом, Мы можем просто ему деньги начислять на счет, и он может пользоваться нашими услугами внутри. То есть это чаще всего, скорее всего, подойдет
Говорящий 2: для тех, кто является нашими, так сказать, клиентами. Но это тоже потом обсуждаемо, скорее всего, в ручном режиме, если кому -то надо будет вывести партнерские деньги, каким -то образом
Говорящий 2: мы там перезачтемся. Но лучше, чтобы имели юридический статус. Ну и так как мы опробуем это все в
Говорящий 1: России, юридические статусы
Говорящий 2: это ИП,
Говорящий 1: самозанятые, ИОО, то есть мы можем
Говорящий 2: выводить на эти компании деньги,
Говорящий 1: то есть отправлять
Говорящий 2: по оферте какой -нибудь, по договору официально, то есть с закрывающими документами и так далее. То есть в каких -то исключительных случаях, скорее всего, мы можем тоже физлицам, как
Говорящий 2: я чуть выше сказал, но это нужно там обсуждать, потому что налог мы все равно платим. То есть у российского ИП 6 % налог при достижении 20 миллионов, еще плюс 5 % НДС. И в связи с этим
Говорящий 2: нам лучше, конечно, все проводить в белую. Вот
Говорящий 1: это такой ретический момент озвучил. Значит,
Говорящий 2: здесь так сказать онбординг, то есть кто, чем занимаетесь, то есть здесь может быть вообще блогер, там не важно кто там, просто мамочка в декрете, не важно номер там и почта. Правила
Говорящий 1: приняли,
Говорящий 2: пошли дальше на онбординге. Вот как раз таки то, что говорил, да, самозанятый индивидуальный предприниматель, ну слэш ООО можно. Вот, мы здесь сейчас не будем в глубину лезть а -ля
Говорящий 2: какое у вас там налогообложение. Главное, что у нас налогообложение сейчас 6%. Если мы перешагнем порог в 20 миллионов и НДС 5%, мы тогда будем менять, пока заморачиваться над этим
Говорящий 2: не надо. Это я зачем опять же вот этот флоу сейчас тебе
Говорящий 1: рассказываю, потому что если,
Говорящий 2: например, у нас партнер ООО с НДС, и мы с НДС 5%, а у него НДС 20%, то там идет у него перезачет этого НДС. Мы как бы ему выплачиваем деньги с НДС, и ему это хорошо. То есть НДСные
Говорящий 2: компании любят работать с НДСными компаниями, так им деньги на 20 % легче. То есть последний, кто оказывает услугу, ну по сути, к кому пришли деньги последнему в цепочке, тот платит
Говорящий 2: НДС. А все предыдущие контрагенты
Говорящий 1: в цепочке этот НДС перекладывают на последнего,
Говорящий 2: к кому придут эти деньги. Поэтому такой интересный налог. Просто проговорил как минимум. Да, ну то есть смотри, у физических лиц и у самозанятых, у них вывод на номер карты, там счета.
Говорящий 2: Понятное дело, здесь это все в
Говорящий 1: сокращенном варианте, но нужно будет там BIC, вот все эти банковские реквизиты подгружать. То есть физлицо от самозанятого чем отличается? Что самозанятый еще выбивает чек. То есть
Говорящий 2: мы ему, например, отправили деньги, к нему пришли, и он нам должен прислать чек. То есть он тоже платит при зачислении от юрлица и ИП 6%, при зачислении денег от физлица 4%. Но мы как
Говорящий 2: ИП будем платить, поэтому нам чек с 6 % нужен будет. Вот, ну, индивидуальный предприниматель либо ООО, там у них тоже,
Говорящий 1: я дополню здесь всеми, так сказать, реквизитами, которые нужны для подключения такого партнера. Вот,
Говорящий 2: тут смотри, какой момент не затрагивается. В работе с индивидуальными предпринимателями и юрлицами есть еще ЭДО, электронный документ оборот. Мы вообще, скорее всего, в эту сторону
Говорящий 2: не смотрели, и будем по мере необходимости, там, подключим этот контур диадок, там, как -то посмотрим уже потом интеграции, можно ли будет сюда там все эти интеграции подгружать. То
Говорящий 2: есть на старте мы, я просто проговариваю, что в эту сторону тоже будет система расширяться, если все запустится и пойдут деньги. Но мы
Говорящий 1: сейчас это опускаем. Но рано или поздно это сделаем.
Говорящий 1: Говорю, да, да, да, понял. Да, то есть рано или поздно это нужно будет сделать, если это все запустится, потому что как бы вручную каждого партнера, кто бы этим не занимался, этим не
Говорящий 1: ты
Говорящий 2: будешь заниматься, в любом случае у вас разработка, то есть будет скорее всего человек на это направление поставлен, который будет документооборотом заниматься,
Говорящий 1: либо бухгалтер, то там можно закопаться, то есть это не ручная работа точно. Но я проговариваю, что развитие будет в этом направлении. Дальше. По
Говорящий 2: условиям. Мы пришли к такой формуле, что партнер получает 35 % от стоимости, которую платит семья. Есть минимальная цена, по которой договорились делать расчет. Это 20 тысяч рублей.
Говорящий 2: То есть 20 000 рублей это цена, ниже которой сформировать индивидуальную ссылку и предложение в кабинете невозможно. Рекомендуемое, чтобы рынок, скажем так, продавал этот продукт, а
Говорящий 2: продукт профориентация автоматическая. Пока что Максим говорит, если будут продажи, я на первоначальных этапах тоже консультации
Говорящий 1: буду брать, чтобы
Говорящий 2: там обратную связь брать, собирать. Но в целом у нас будет без консультации продукт, как он задуман сейчас после скрининга. Рекомендуемая цена 35 и верхнюю границу мы отменяем. То есть
Говорящий 2: у нас по сути система такая, чем дороже ты продаешь
Говорящий 1: как партнер, тем больше самостоятельно и зарабатываешь. То есть продаешь дешевле, зарабатываешь меньше. И это вот такая приведена таблица
Говорящий 2: по стоимости, которую ты получаешь как партнер. Тут оговорюсь по поводу того, чтобы считалось все правильно для нас. Смотри, вот например, партнер привел 20 тысяч рублей. Мы с полной
Говорящий 2: стоимости должны будем заплатить 6%. То есть 6 % это 1200 рублей. То есть мы получается партнеру отдаем 7 и 1200 налоги. У нас плюс эквайринг, там всякие расходы. Возьмем это 10 % наши.
Говорящий 2: То есть минус 7 и минус 2. То есть мы получим как компания 11. Но мы заинтересованы в том, чтобы партнер продавал дороже. И соответственно и он зарабатывал больше и мы. То есть почему
Говорящий 2: взяли не фиксированную какую -то стоимость для компании, а взяли вот такой процент, потому что там начали считать, и модель показывала, что чем больше стоимость программы, тем мы платим
Говорящий 2: больше налог, и в некоторых моментах мы можем даже уйти в минус. То есть условно говоря, если бы мы поставили просто нам 20, а все, что выше, то когда налог достигает 20 тысяч рублей,
Говорящий 2: например, кто -то очень дорого продал или за миллион продал, то мы платим 60 тысяч налога плюс эквайринг, то есть мы минус 1070 можем получить, нам это не надо. Поэтому такая система.
Говорящий 2: Это я тебе проговариваю, почему именно так.
Говорящий 2: Когда ты проектировал потом борт по доходу, ты понимал, что у нас есть расходная часть налога, У нас есть расходная часть эквайринг. Здесь надо будет с
Говорящий 1: Сашей поговорить, потому что в эквайринге там тоже есть... Короче, я не знаю, может я сильно глубоко лезу, но проговорить мне кажется
Говорящий 2: это все тоже нужно, потому что это расчет денег компании. В эквайринге есть две системы, так сказать, снятия этого процента. Один это система быстрых переводов. Там по -моему 0 ,7 %
Говорящий 2: от стоимости комиссия. И второй это банковский эквайринг. То есть банк, ну там, к примеру, там Сбербанк, Альфа -банк, Т -банк, они могут
Говорящий 1: брать, условно говоря, от 1 ,7 до 3 ,5 % за одну сделку, за один чек, в зависимости от условий пакета. И там,
Говорящий 2: условно говоря, чем у тебя дороже пакет, тем у тебя эквайринг ниже. Ну, либо там разные механики есть, то есть вот это уже с Сашей мы, что мы тебе предоставим чуть позже информацию.
Говорящий 2: То есть это тоже влияет на вот эти вот, знаешь, проценты, которые в итоге компания получит на остаточную стоимость денег. Плюс есть еще стоимость этих денег вывода с ИП, потому что
Говорящий 2: некоторые банки берут, например, 1%, кто -то 0%, кто -то там миллион бесплатно себе на карту, а дальше выше. То есть мы вот эти вот уже нюансы будем в P &L, в доход компании считать
Говорящий 2: позже. Но сейчас
Говорящий 1: я проговариваю,
Говорящий 2: что такое есть. И поэтому здесь, например, мы в глубину в эту не идем, просто чтобы сейчас не упороться.
Говорящий 2: Делаем проще. Я понял. Да,
Говорящий 1: делаем проще. По мере, скажем так, масштаба и проблемы мы будем их уже решать.
Говорящий 2: Дальше смотри. В кабинете должен быть новое предложение, которое может сформировать сам партнер. Вот этот ползунок.
Говорящий 2: Соответственно, минимальный 20, не знаю, что он 18 сделал.
Говорящий 1: Короче, 20 должен
Говорящий 2: быть минимальный.
Говорящий 1: Не знаю, что он 20 сделал. 18, короче. Ну, в общем,
Говорящий 2: от 20 до должна быть, что вот рекомендуемая цена, видишь, и вам начисляться. И к выплате вам вот столько. И как бы человек сам формирует. Можно срок убрать. вот можно там назвать это
Говорящий 2: там для там саши
Говорящий 2: вот создать
Говорящий 1: предложение вот он там создает это предложение
Говорящий 1: соответственно сейчас я назад
Говорящий 2: вернусь пойду по flow вот у него эти предложения видишь есть здесь, они фиксируются, то есть я могу для Саши 2 здесь создать предложение, я не знаю какую -нибудь сумму, то есть я пока
Говорящий 2: тут в MVP -120, по -моему, или 150 тысяч, 120 тысяч, но можно, условно говоря, и до 500 поставить этот ползунок, и знаешь, как с такими какими -то
Говорящий 2: чтобы
Говорящий 1: было понятно, какая стоимость идет.
Говорящий 1: Ладно, пойдем дальше в предложения.
Говорящий 2: Вот эти предложения есть.
Говорящий 2: Мы, соответственно, как партнер видит это все, мы даем ему ссылку, то есть он скопировал и по этой ссылке, Как сейчас, например, есть бесплатная, есть одна цена, есть другая. Точно
Говорящий 2: так же формируется автоматическая цена, которую партнер сформировал в приглашении. Либо, как у нас есть промокоды,
Говорящий 1: партнер может давать промокод.
Говорящий 1: Что здесь дальше может сформироваться? Такой простенький лендинг. там у нас есть по профориентации, можно на него добавить
Говорящий 2: информацию, что это рекомендует какой -то партнер и купить за вот эту стоимость. И можно, соответственно, остановить предложение, либо еще какое -то предложение создать. Понятное дело,
Говорящий 2: что лучше его создавать
Говорящий 1: здесь.
Говорящий 2: Почему здесь по 35? Потому что это рекомендуемая цена. То есть я думаю, что большинство будут стартовать,
Говорящий 1: конечно, с меньшей, потом с уровнем продаж будут всем продавать по 35 стараться, либо дороже. Но можно и не создавать, если это необязательная кнопка. Ну, в общем,
Говорящий 1: пусть пока будет, чтобы
Говорящий 2: мы стимулировали их делать как бы рынок все по одной цене. Так, ну, соответственно, следующая страница семьи, я тебе уже по факту ее чуть ранее
Говорящий 1: рассказал. Так, по поводу оплат. Значит, статистика у нас
Говорящий 2: вытягивается из метрики, сколько по ссылкам перешло, сколько было там обращение оплат и, соответственно, в каком статусе.
Говорящий 2: То есть он понимает, что это там какой -то заказ для такого -то человека от такой -то даты, по такой -то цене начислено. И вот когда, например,
Говорящий 2: услуга будет оказана, смотри, у нас здесь правило должно
Говорящий 1: быть такое, что деньги можно выводить через 7
Говорящий 2: дней после того, как оказана услуга. Ну,
Говорящий 1: то есть это такое, знаешь. Да. Ну, я видел в отчете, да, ты мне
Говорящий 2: штуки дал. Там я, в принципе, это уже и сделал. Я многое сделал из этого. У нас было многое сделано, я еще твои правки, которые ты по презентациям кидал, я их сделал. Вот, касаемо этого
Говорящий 2: тоже, что там услуга должна быть завершена, время должно с этого времени
Говорящий 1: пройти. Все эти моментики я учел. О, супер, супер. Ну, в общем, да,
Говорящий 2: должен быть, скажем так, общий flow по
Говорящий 2: статусам сделки, то есть должен понимать, например, партнер, что там происходит. И вот я там написал по вторникам, можно, например, действительно какой -нибудь день выбрать, тот же
Говорящий 2: вторник, и мы просто
Говорящий 1: партнером по вторникам отправляем деньги. Почему один день? Такая бухгалтерская фишка, особенно компании, когда растут, и еще пока ручной труд, мы, возможно, потом это правило отменим,
Говорящий 1: но часто бухгалтера говорят, давайте так, мы берем вот
Говорящий 2: один день, платежки все
Говорящий 1: вносим
Говорящий 2: и все оплачиваем. Ну и вот поэтому тоже для тебя. Зачем это делается, как бы объясняю, потому что часто
Говорящий 1: так бухгалтера такие. Ну да, на
Говорящий 2: примере ОВБ тоже они вроде бы так делают, выплаты по определенным дням именно.
Говорящий 1: Да, типа не хочу заниматься этим всю неделю, давай вот конкретно этой задачей я буду заниматься один день в неделю. Потому
Говорящий 2: что есть еще другие задачи.
Говорящий 1: Так, дальше что у нас?
Говорящий 1: Ну
Говорящий 2: это вот рассматриваем кейс возврата. Значит, у нас, если запрос возврата денег, то мы, соответственно,
Говорящий 2: должны либо пересчитывать. Но вообще желательно, знаешь, как по поводу возвратов. Видишь, я не думаю, что у нас будет абуз системы, но такой негативный сценарий тоже нужно посмотреть.
Говорящий 2: Что, например, мы выплатили,
Говорящий 1: а у нас потом запросили возврат.
Говорящий 1: Чтобы не было вот этого всего, я почему -то изначально 14 дней ставил, потому что по закону попросить возврат можно в течение 14 дней. Но у нас по факту должно быть в системе условие,
Говорящий 1: что услуга выполнена.
Говорящий 2: Поэтому, опять же, возвращаясь к правилам, я тебе сейчас озвучу, что
Говорящий 1: для меня, скорее всего, идеально, что, например,
Говорящий 1: либо закончилась услуга, либо она уже оплачена
Говорящий 2: в течение 14 дней. То есть, вот этот холд на 14 дней, он как будто бы Прямо напрашивается, потому что действительно мы можем через 7 дней, вот сегодня пришел человек, сегодня прошел,
Говорящий 2: мы через 7 дней выплатили, а потом еще через 3 дня человек говорит, верните мне деньги. Ну понятное дело, что тут нужно рассматривать, что алло, ребят, ну какой возврат,
Говорящий 1: вы же услугу получили, получили.
Говорящий 2: Вот, то есть тут будет в индивидуальном порядке. Ну я надеюсь, что у нас такого не будет всего. Но если будет прецедент, нам нужно, чтобы эти 14 дней с момента покупки прошли.
Говорящий 2: То есть что наступит быстрее? Либо просто наступило 14 дней с покупки, либо прошло 7 дней после того, как прошли услугу, но уже спустя эти 14 дней. понимаешь
Говорящий 1: да да да ну вот эти в телегу скинул вот эту вот строку я выдернул из отчета получается по формулировке именно вот ну что то да да да
Говорящий 2: да да
Говорящий 1: да супер так
Говорящий 1: панель партнера соответственно
Говорящий 1: общее его состояние. Ну и по сути все. Помощь еще есть, например,
Говорящий 1: тикет. Тикет, я думаю, что
Говорящий 2: нужно будет создать почту, либо вот там есть почта у нас. Но я такой приверженец, чтобы не путать все это в один поток, там, где у нас на Rambler почта. Скорее всего на Main Experts,
Говорящий 2: там какой -нибудь надо будет партнерс собака, main experts, там, ком или онлайн, вот, и туда пусть прилетают запросы, чтобы... Ну, у нас еще есть, если что, работает этот, как он, обсуждение
Говорящий 2: в телеге называется, топ -кит, или как он там называется, ну, типа беседы, и туда вот эти вот запросы могут прилетать, то есть мы можем настроить, чтобы оно также улетало просто в телегу
Говорящий 2: нам, как в
Говорящий 1: фото. Там, где лиды сейчас падают, да?
Говорящий 2: Ну да, вот сейчас я тебе покажу, где -то за скринью у меня он был,
Говорящий 1: поддержка, вот
Говорящий 2: поддержка MainExpert.
Говорящий 1: Я открываю, и оно выглядит так. Я могу тебе дать доступ к экрану.
Говорящий 1: Сейчас.
Говорящий 2: Так, демонстрация.
Говорящий 1: Вот, смотри, вот этот вот я делал, получается, в формате группы. И у нас получается вот
Говорящий 2: здесь вот я добавлял Сашу и Вадима, ну и бот наш тут добавлен. Короче, человек, когда оставляет запрос, он вот таким вот чатом делается, и мы на него можем отвечать, соответственно,
Говорящий 2: брать в работу и отвечать. там условно какой -нибудь идти берем такой вот тема и так далее от какого пользователя ну и мы можем ответить ему ему придет ответ то есть это также у нас
Говорящий 2: хранится в базе данных и можем это отслеживать то есть не обязательно для этого там почту использовать такой формат мне кажется даже будет
Говорящий 1: более удобный но в целом да согласен просто не все пользуются телеграммом да есть большая аудитории особенно в европе которая не пользуется телеграма рада и это это не к тому что им
Говорящий 1: telegram пользоваться нам пользоваться им то приходит ответ там в личном кабинал
Говорящий 2: им нашим на а это только мы просто отвечаем ответ он приходит там
Говорящий 1: супер
Говорящий 1: слушай ну хорошо давай тогда так
Говорящий 2: бы эту систему не писать но хорошо так
Говорящий 1: ну по сути может вопросы какие то есть да нет на самом деле я очень много там читал потому что
Говорящий 2: ты кидал и в принципе я уже там все моменты закрыл кроме вот как раз получается
Говорящий 2: панели
Говорящий 1: то что ты показал партнером кабинета
Говорящий 2: партнера в
Говорящий 1: остальном принципе там уже все что реализовано. Единственное, что я тебе говорил про организации, это, наверное, ты чуть -чуть не так понял,
Говорящий 2: про что я говорил, у нас система организации закладывалась в том направлении, что мы в дальнейшем позиционируем себя не только как одну организацию на платформе MainExperts, а как типа
Говорящий 2: платформа, в которую могут приходить какие -то еще дополнительные агентства, школы и так далее. и у каждой такой организации может быть своя условно ставка партнерская. И ее можно указывать.
Говорящий 2: Допустим, какая -то организация указала 30%, какая -то 50%,
Говорящий 1: какая -то 10%. Вот об этом я там говорил. Но в целом... Извини, продолжай, я думал, закончу.
Говорящий 2: И то, что партнер приводит, получается, пользователя именно в какую -то конкретную организацию, и отчисления идут от нее. То есть, если он купил у другой организации уже, там отчисления
Говорящий 2: не идут. И это тоже влияет на партнерку сильно, чтобы мы лишние отчисления никакие не делали
Говорящий 1: там партнеру, который привел не в ту организацию.
Говорящий 1: Слушай, здесь нужно подумать, потому что смотри,
Говорящий 2: была такая идея, что партнеры могут рекомендовать не только, например, профориентацию, которая сейчас есть, а любой продукт на платформе и от него получать. То есть это получается вообще
Говорящий 2: отдельная надстройка, которая не привязывает получение денег в зависимости от организации. То есть это отдельная сущность, отдельный слой получается. который ну вот смотри сейчас пример
Говорящий 2: приведу например я профориентолог или
Говорящий 1: там я учитель английского я привел пользователя это мы сейчас начинаем с профориентации но потом например
Говорящий 2: я понимаю что провел профориентацию еще и на этом заработал и или ссылку скинул там заработал на И
Говорящий 1: там нужно будет ученику, которого я привел, подтянуть математику.
Говорящий 2: А ты учитель математики. У нас дальше будет какое развитие? Например, ты учитель математики, но ты тоже в партнерскую программу заходишь. И для уроков ты, например, ставишь... Это отдельный
Говорящий 2: слой, мы просто его сейчас пока не проговариваем, но мы уже его обсуждали, как это будет работать. Ты, например, как учитель математики ставишь на свои предметы, вот в партнерский marketplace,
Говорящий 2: скажем так, ты готов отдавать партнерам 30
Говорящий 1: % или 20%, то есть ты можешь сам поставить сколько процентов ты готов отдавать в партнерскую сеть. Например, 5 % заберет
Говорящий 2: платформа и 25 % партнер, который приведет. И вот я, понимая, что ты классный эксперт, у тебя высокий процент, я порекомендую, например, дальше пойти к тебе. И я буду зарабатывать на
Говорящий 2: том, что ты проводишь занятия, но ты уже являешься другой организацией. Соответственно, партнерская программа, она не должна привязывать
Говорящий 1: доход только к организации.
Говорящий 1: Я понял. Ну да, да, да. Это такой вполне логичный сценарий.
Говорящий 1: Вот.
Говорящий 1: Ну, это по большей части, да, нужно прорабатывать,
Говорящий 2: когда у нас будет какой -то набор организаций, а не так, что мы там одна организация и все. на платформе. Часто в любом случае мы одной организацией, и у каждой организации есть свой
Говорящий 2: набор экспертов. Допустим, в начале мы в любом случае идем таким образом, что мы как одна организация со своим пулом экспертов. Эксперт по математике, эксперт по другим урокам и так
Говорящий 2: далее. И это в рамках одной организации работает, и никаких проблем не возникает. Проблемы могут возникнуть, когда мы даем возможность регистрироваться другим экспертом как отдельным
Говорящий 2: организациям у нас.
Говорящий 1: Тогда уже надо будет проработать детальнее.
Говорящий 1: Да, ну я тебе тоже накинул этот контекст, чтобы понимал, что там потом при развитии платформы партнерка будет шире, чем просто в пределах одной организации.
Говорящий 1: Это знаешь, вот,
Говорящий 2: но эксперты, они немножко побаиваются конкуренции, а по факту, если друг друга будут рекомендовать, неважно какой они организации привязаны, то есть они будут просто зарабатывать
Говорящий 1: больше в этом интересе. Это и партнерская программа.
Говорящий 1: Ну, понятное дело,
Говорящий 2: что там мы тоже будем ограничивать, наверное, не больше 30%. Потому что, условно говоря, 50 -70 % от своего дохода отдавать партнеру, это, наверное, уже... Продолжение следует...